Red Alert everybody super-secret Rick
and Morty stuff is happening later this
week so I'll explain what's going on
because it is going to be awesome the
merch giveaway that I started in my last
video seemed pretty popular so we'll
just keep that going there's a new round
in this video all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video and I'll name a new winner
at the end of this but if you didn't see
Rick and Morty is doing something
special this Thursday night 9 p.m.
Eastern Time they haven't said what
they're doing but it's an actual
physical secret they say secret location
where they're going to broadcast but it
sounds like because this was announced
right after that big controversy about
all the fake news about the show being
canceled this is very clearly them
talking to each other like they probably
saw that news and said hey we should do
something cool for the fans to make them
chill out a little bit let them know
that everything's okay we're not sitting
on episodes just to make them mad so
what they might do is another repeat of
the April Fool's Day joke where they
drop a new episode because the event
they're doing is an hour-long episodes
are only about 22 minutes so what they
might do just a combination of Rick and
Morty themed harmontown
with new material if you've never seen
Harmon town it's a weekly comedy show
the Dan Harmon actually started doing
way back after he got fired off of
community this is a sort of catharsis
some way to do something creative while
he was working on other projects but he
liked doing it so much and it became
popular so he just continued to do it
every week they said the Rick and Morty
location where they're going is supposed
to be secret but they literally just
turned the starburns Castle into this
big broadcasting live streaming place so
that might be where this thing is going
to be happening but they're also doing
the Rick mobile they're also doing that
grassroots tour where they go around
they show new material from all the
other Adult Swim programs but the way
they're hyping it up don't miss it or be
late trust us just makes it sound like
something new is going to be shown up
whatever it is I will totally do a video
for it but just because it's Thursday
doesn't mean the show is going to be a
Thursday show typically the Adult Swim
stream is Saturday nights and it's
Sunday nights on TV Rick and Morty in
the past has been a Sunday night show
and it's usually on much later in the
evening so this feels like a one-time
deal
they haven't done too many repeats of
that first episode I figured they would
actually just repeat it more and more as
we got closer to the season but when
they did that April Fool's Day joke they
actually just streamed it over and over
they literally looped the episode until
the end of that night so you could have
watched it like six or seven times by
the end of the evening because we're
getting so close to the actual premiere
they actually do have a handful of
episodes that are done but I think that
they're waiting till most of them are
done so they can air them without any
breaks and the wiki actually says that
they're supposed to be 14 episodes I
haven't seen anything that's verified
that number so at least 10 possibly 14
it would make sense that if Rick and
Morty is growing in popularity they
would increase the episode count but
here's an interview with them talking
about the whole of season 3 I'll post
the rest of this if you guys want it's
actually a pretty cool interview I mean
he gets out of jail immediately oh yeah
I mean it's like cold open we got nachos
Rick and Morty so I mean this season in
general without spoiling it I will say
it's very exciting where we're exploring
characters that we haven't all the way
explored yet namely Beth and summer I
think like especially on the best side
like I feel like Beth has always been
she's just been Rick's daughter and this
season we get we dig in a little more to
that character and you know it's there's
a lot of it's like people thought that
the first season was like it was funny
and had a little bit of darkness and
then the second season got even it was
the dark season kind of like it was like
oh we explore the consequences of Rick
yeah on other people but but we have to
reek at agura is that because the third
season gets really done it really are
vague we explore it's not that there's
an episode the Rick gets themselves into
a metaphorical pickle and basically not
that it's a yank of baking of gravity or
127 hours but it's Rick's lone survivor
episode story so it's like what what
happens if Rick it's really from some of
his own actions and kind he suffers the
consequences trying to make it through
so it's kind of like going into an
episode where the RV it runs out of
battering in the desert when they have
to like try to make potato batteries
exactly the focusing in on the mattock
Kilis minutiae of a really particular
jeopardy that's Rick isn't yeah Rick's
speaking of early Rick's you actually
see how his brain you know a lot of
times ago like he goes I'm going to make
a fluke we do quantum sizer cut to a
floopy to quantify so really we don't
know how he made it we actually just
feel like he's in a situation with
limited resources how it is genius get
him out of that with limited you know we
should take you through it the whole
sort of process obviously the pickle
episode that he's talking about was the
preview that they released last year the
animatic that they brought to Comic Con
[Music]
[Applause]
so because the season hasn't aired in
comic-con is next month they might bring
new material from season 3 but they
might also be talking about season 4
like oh you think season 3 is dark
season 4 is going to be the darkest of
them all but if there was any wonder
after all that cancellation drama yes
they'll continue to make Rick and Morty
I mean he said 9 seasons he said it at
the end of the first episode so prophecy
confirmed if community can make it to
six seasons in a movie and that show is
way less popular than Rick and Morty is
right now then they can totally get
there with Rick and Morty believe all
your requests for Rick and Morty videos
in the comments below I'll say
congratulations to the first giveaway
winner King Clovis please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details in
just a heads up if you're new to the
channel and you're entering a giveaway
you don't have to comment that you're
entering the giveaway just like any
comment will do it's totally fine but
while you wait for everything you can
click here for all the season 3 promos
and you can click here for brand-new
Game of Thrones thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]